dans les villes ukrainiennes libérées
les traces des exactions russes
continuent à émerger 4 sites de tortures
utilisés par Moscou ont été découverts à
Carson selon Kiev dans le sud de
l'Ukraine à quelques kilomètres de là
ces deux hommes racontent les sévices
subis
pas de toilettes rien nous devions
utiliser des bouteilles on avait donc
peur de manger alors même qu'on était
nourris qu'une fois par jour
Vladimir et Sergueï ont été arrêtés le
22 juin dernier ils ont alors été
conduits dans ce centre de détention où
ils ont selon eux étaient torturés
pendant 7 jours consécutifs
la plupart du temps les Russes m'ont
battu avec du courant électrique le
courant touché mes pieds mes mains mes
oreilles quand vous aurez sont touchés
vous changés rapidement à ce stade
Moscou n'a pas réagi à ses accusations
qui avaient dénoncer à plusieurs
reprises de guerre dans la région de
Carson sur place les habitants libérés
des russes depuis plus de 10 jours non
eux toujours pas d'eau ni d'électricité
cet hiver mettra en danger la vie de
millions de personnes en Ukraine alors
que la crise humanitaire menace à Carson
la ville continue à être la cible de
bombardements russes les autorités ont
d'ores et déjà exhorté les habitants à
partir faire des zones plus sûres